[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing one of if not
the most powerful wizard to have ever
lived merlin
you've probably heard of merlin before
and if not
i'm sure you've at least heard the
expression merlin's beard
which is commonly used by dumbledore and
expresses surprise
merlin is a particularly interesting
character because he didn't only exist
in harry potter folklore he existed in
our folklore as well
we see the same sort of thing with
nicholas flamel however
it should be mentioned that there are a
few differences between the two merlins
the merlin from our own folklore was a
legendary figure known across the lands
as a prominent enchanter and wizard he
was most notably featured in
arthurian legend but was also a
prominent figure
in medieval welsh poetry the concept of
merlin
that we're most familiar with first
appears in jeffrey of monmouth's famous
work entitled
historia regum britannia the book was
first published in 1136
and is essentially a pseudo-historical
account of british history
following the lives of the kings of
britain over the millennia
merlin was created when geoffrey
combined two prominent historical
figures
miradin wilt a north brethonic prophet
and ambrosius aurelianis
a romano british warleader however the
story that we most commonly associate
with merlin in our own culture is the
story of king arthur
the knights of the round table the story
which has been subject to copious
adaptations over the years
tells the tales of king arthur his court
his kingdom
and his most trustworthy men the knights
of the round table were a sub-order of
the knights of camelot
created by arthur pendragon and they
helped him with whatever quarrels he had
to deal with
in one story even helping him to combat
his sister
organa pendragon and her attempts to
conquer camelot
in the realm of this universe's merlin
he's a powerful sorcerer
and the trusted and wise advisor of
arthur however what is most interesting
about merlin is that he's such an
enigmatic figure
he's the subject of much discussion
widely because his existence
has been adapted in so many ways and
slaughtered into so many different
stories
there's a certain allure about merlin
because he's this figure that's
supposedly immensely wise and powerful
but there's still so much that is
unknown about him
the fact that he appears in so many
different tales myths and legends
only adds to this mystique i mean he
even ended up in harry potter
and though merlin isn't explicitly
mentioned much in harry potter
he does pop up here and there he's the
reason the phrase merlin's beard exists
as i mentioned earlier he's on a
hogwarts portrait he's on a chocolate
frog card
and he's even the founder of an
organization called the order of merlin
it has been expressed that the order of
merlin was founded by merlin
during the middle ages created with the
goal of promoting laws to protect and
benefit muggles
while it was once an organization it
later became an award
honoring impressive accomplishments or
good deeds there are three different
levels of the award
first class second class and third class
the three levels of the award can be
distinguished by the color of the ribbon
which holds up a large golden medal
first class was awarded for
acts of outstanding bravery or
distinction in magic and was represented
by a green ribbon
second class was awarded for achievement
or endeavor beyond the ordinary
and was represented by a purple ribbon
and third class was awarded for
contributions to knowledge or
entertainment and was represented by
a white ribbon being a recipient of the
order of merlin
was a huge honor and can be compared to
being knighted in our own world
albus dumbledore was the recipient of
this award after his prominent defeat of
gaelic grindelwald
in 1945. merlin was a strong believer
that the muggle and wizarding worlds
should coexist and founded the original
organization
in an effort to help alleviate any
complications associated
with the coalescence of the two worlds
in the middle ages especially there was
a lot of conflict between muggles and
wizards
the wizarding world was essentially wide
open and muggles knew that witches and
wizards walked among them
however rather than embracing them for
their magical abilities
muggles were exceedingly harsh when it
came to dealing with magical folk
they treated them like freaks like spawn
of the devil and hunted them down in
purges called
witch hunts what this tells me about
merlin's character
is that he was particularly pure of
heart as he was able to take the moral
high ground
and still considered the greater good of
the world when his own people were being
persecuted
the secondary goal of merlin's
organization was to create laws and
legislation
surrounding the use of magic on muggles
i think that this was definitely a step
in the right direction
but unfortunately the conflict between
muggles and wizard kind
proved too difficult to manage as the
worlds eventually needed to separate
entirely
for balance to be found the wizarding
world which had a much smaller
population
had to retreat into the shadows creating
their own new world
with the use of concealment charms
though the exact year is not specified
we know that the merlin from the harry
potter universe was born sometime in a
medieval era
a period in history ranging from the 5th
century to 15th century
this is quite a broad range of dates but
fortunately given the fact that we know
he attended hogwarts
we can narrow this down a bit more some
sources indicate that merlin was born in
a.d which would make him one of the very
first students at hogwarts
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry was founded in the year 990 a.d
which would mean that merlin attended
school just a few years after it opened
its doors
when he started at the school he was
sorted into slytherin
so if merlin attended the school during
this period then it would also mean that
he would have been directly taught by
founder
salazar sutherin other sources speculate
that he was a student
sometime between the 11th and 15th
century however
i'm inclined to lean towards the former
theory because i think that some of
merlin's power
could be attributed to him having a
teacher as powerful as salazar slytherin
however based on merlin's perspective on
muggle wizarding relations
i don't expect that salazar rubbed off
on him too much
a birth year of 1982 would also likely
be more consistent with arthurian legend
as those stories took place in the 11th
and 12th
century and merlin was already quite old
and wise
no one knows exactly how merlin was born
or who his parents were
but there are some theories and i'm
going to share the one that seemed to be
most consistent with arthurian legend
legend has it that merlin was the son of
a noble woman
and an incubus or demon some versions of
the tale
portray her as the daughter of the king
of northumberland
shortly after merlin's birth the little
one was baptized and cleansed of his
demonic inheritance
a paradoxical figure he embodies an
encounter between good and evil
a kindly servant endowed by his father
with supernatural powers
however as we've seen there are a lot of
differences between the merlin of
arthurian legend
and the merlin in the harry potter
universe so this could potentially be
all wrong
while attending the school merlin proved
to be an exceptionally gifted wizard
particularly in the realm of charms
earning his title of
the prince of enchanters this is
supported by merlin's very own chocolate
frog card
which was created to immortalize him
after his demise
medieval dates unknown most famous
wizard of all time
sometimes known as the prince of
enchanters part of the court of king
arthur
merlin is also the source of much pride
for slytherin house
as they were the house that produced
perhaps the most powerful and definitely
the most famous wizard in history
while attending the school merlin
studied the cursed vaults hogwarts in
great detail
five legendary rooms hidden inside
hogwarts walls that house priceless
treasures and powerful magical artifacts
before his death merlin further
immortalized himself by painting his own
portrait
then enchanting it and hanging it on the
wall of the school his portrait would
then serve to inform people
about the cursed vaults however his
messages were cryptic
and hard to understand the only
character that we've seen that we know
merlin to have definitively interacted
with
was sir cadogan who was a fellow wizard
and knight of the round table
like merlin circa dogan's portrait hangs
on the walls of hogwarts
and his particular portrait can be found
at the end of the divination corridor
cadogan might just be the closest
connection we have to the enigma that is
merlin
many speculate that merlin was the most
powerful wizard of all time
no questions asked and i think there's
certainly an argument here
his title of the prince of enchanters
tells us right away that he was more
versed in charms magic than anyone else
and charms are one of the most difficult
forms of magic to master
he was also a master of wonderless magic
though he did have a wand
and he even created a number of the
spells that witches and wizards commonly
use today
expelliarmus have you heard of it that
was merlin
merlin is such an interesting figure the
most powerful and famous wizard to have
ever lived
yet we still don't know so much about
him who were his primary adversaries
did he know rexydian or acrystus how did
he achieve such high levels of power
who were his parents was he a pureblood
half blood
muggleborn we just don't know and i
think that these are the things that
make his character
so compelling what do you guys know
about merlin there are so many different
stories and myths and tales that speak
of him
i know i've only scratched the surface
do me a favor and comment down below
what you know about merlin so that i can
learn a little bit more myself
until next time you're a wizard howie
[Music]
you